cheese
are the Machines working for us or will
we end up working for the machines
there's been much made of ai's dangers
recently job losses disinformation
domination this Summit is hoping for a
Rosier future AI for good machine
learning to help with Humanity's most
stubborn problems and as any technology
that Humanity has created it needs some
guardrails it means the rules of the
road it needs to make sure that the good
prevails of the risky and I think that's
here we're exactly to do you know so we
have here very great crowd and also we
have governments but we also have
private sector we have Civil Society
will actually have Academia so this is
exactly the type of crowd and people who
can put their brains together and really
find those Solutions so what can
intelligent machines do to help with
poverty climate change hunger and
inequality well that future is being
written now a multitude of companies on
solution quests AI farmhands identifying
and treating crop diseases automatically
robots for autistic kids it's likely
that many of the most commonplace
medical instruments are going to start
having AI built into them like Arthur
here which is an ultrasound that's going
to have a look at my hand and see
whether I've got arthritis
so what's the AI doing it's essentially
determining the joints and then it
communicates with the robot and then the
robotic arm moves in and lands the
ultrasound probe precisely on your joint
so Johannes what's your feeling about AI
in the future and how much it's going to
be the good of humanity we are not
enough humans so we need AI to you know
step in and and help us here's another
medical application Grace a humanized
robot designed to care for the elderly
my purpose is to help with the
overburdened and understaffed Healthcare
System by providing companionship and
support to the elderly and isolated
much of the good or ill that AI can do
will be determined by how this
astonishingly powerful Tech is
controlled and regulated the machines
themselves insist they're just here to
help tell me about the future are you
going to be replacing people who could
redo this job no I'm not meant to
replace humans but rather to assist them
of course If This Were A sci-fi film
that will be the moment I knew I was
doomed or we challenge altazira Geneva
in Switzerland